se vive el renacimiento de la izquierda
en Latinoamérica por primera vez en la
historia las cinco principales economías
de la región estarán gobernadas por el
izquierdismo el mapa empezó a dibujarse
en julio de 2018 con El Triunfo de
Andrés Manuel López Obrador en México le
siguió Alberto Fernández en Argentina en
2019 y se completó con Gabriel borich en
chile y Gustavo Petro en Colombia la
izquierda también hace presencia en
Venezuela Cuba Nicaragua Perú o Bolivia
sin embargo la fuerza progresista de
este tiempo tiene un panorama mucho más
difícil que el de la marea rosa de
comienzos de siglo cuando Venezuela
Argentina chile Brasil Bolivia y Uruguay
tenían mandatarios de izquierda en esa
época sus gobiernos gozaban de tener los
precios de sus materias primas por las
nubes y nos enfrentaban a las
consecuencias económicas de una pandemia
la crisis de suministro por la guerra en
Ucrania y una inflación generalizada en
septiembre el índice de precios al
consumidor Fue de más de dos dígitos
para la mayoría de los países de la
región
incluso están en recesión y se espera
que por lo menos dos de ellos superan El
100% de la tasa inflacionaria para final
de año y a pesar del gasto fiscal de los
gobiernos muchos ciudadanos pasaron de
la clase media la pobreza en un panorama
de desaceleración del crecimiento el
fondo monetario internacional la cepal y
otras instituciones económicas han
rebajado las expectativas de crecimiento
para la mayoría de los países de la
región que en 2023 crecerá apenas un
1,4%
. muchos de los presidentes recién
elegidos ya han mermado en el porcentaje
de nivel de aprobación mientras intentan
cumplir sus promesas de pacto tal la
erradicación del hambre la
redistribución de la riqueza la equidad
social y la preservación del medio
ambiente